they prohibited doing things you know
with uh with male private parts that are
very graphic they prohibited pumping
these miners with puberty blockers just
not something that that it's appropriate
so I think those are appropriate guard
rails look there's some parents that
this is something that that they want to
go down that road but I think a lot of
parents you know they just want what's
best for their kid their kid may be
going through something so then they'll
go to a physician and the physician is
pushing this stuff on the family and and
that's just that's wrong and so we're
happy that that we were able to to do
that remember that they've still not
demonstrated to my satisfaction
certainly that Physicians are pushing
things on people
for a lot of these folks explaining
options that exist they say that's a
form of pushing